un 1er mai sans banderoles ni cortège
mais avec des slogans scandés et
diffusée sur internet
les syndicats ont ainsi célébré cette
journée internationale des travailleurs
sur les réseaux sociaux et depuis leurs
balcons concert de casseroles champs ou
encore manifestation en ligne ils ont
malgré tout fait entendre leur voix mais
différemment cette année certains ou
quand même décidé de descendre dans la
rue notamment place de la république à
paris où il ya eu des échauffourées avec
les forces de l'ordre
de leur côté les partis politiques ont
incité leurs militants à prendre part à
un 1er mai en ligne
c'était le cas par exemple du
rassemblement national qui a publié un
discours de marine le pen
cette dernière a de plus bravé
l'interdiction de déplacement en allant
déposer une gerbe devant la statue de
jeanne d'arc à paris tout comme le
faisait son père jean marie le pen
je suis en désaccord certain nombre de
mesures qui sont prises dans le cadre de
ce déconfinement notamment je considère
qu'un déconfinement réussi c'est un
déconfinement avec des tests généralisée
pour tout le monde avec des masques
généralisée pour tout le monde
mis à disposition et je suis totalement
opposé à la réouverture des écoles avant
le mois de septembre
j'ai eu l'occasion de dire cela à des
multiples reprises
une manifestation en ligne c'est aussi
ce qu'a prévu la france est soumise
accompagné d'une casserolade objectif
frapper le plus fort possible sur des
casseroles pour dénoncé l'improvisation
du gouvernement dans la gestion de la
crise du coronavirus de son côté le
parti communiste a créé le hashtag
masqué pas muselée et a donné rendez
vous sur les réseaux sociaux pour une
prise de parole du secrétaire national
fabien roussel le président emmanuel
macron à lui promis dans un message
vidéo que les français retrouveront dès
que possible leur 1er mai ce 1er mai ne
ressemble à aucun autre nom privé des
rituels de cette journée nous en
éprouvons aujourd'hui toute la valeur
tout le sens avec cette volonté forte
retrouver
dès que possible les premiers mais
joyeux chamailleurs parfois qui font
notre nation mes chers compatriotes nous
les retrouverons ces premiers mais
heureux ensemble
unis nous surmonterons cette épreuve
chamailleurs un terme qui ne passe pas
pour l'opposition de gauche qui a hâte
de descendre au plus vite dans la rue
pour la défense des travailleurs